Show me the one whose safety deemed such
destruction
you must reunite it with its own kind
where
the songs of eon's past tell of battles between
mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerers called jedi
you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy
sorcerers
this is the way
you know this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes
So I've heard
this is the way
The next season of
mandalorian is gonna be very interesting
because you're going to start to find
out
the power of the child what the
child really means
you will also start to uncover
the origins of the darksaber that Moff
Gideon has and how that plays into
previous star war history connected to
the clone wars and other shows
and you'll start to get a real
dramatic sense of the territory
we're living in a universe that is you
know just
huge and so much to explore so i think
this show is going to start to lay the
groundwork for the depth and breadth
that's going to come in
season three and season four where
you're really going to start to get answers
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new mandalorian season
2 trailer video we also have that clip
of moff gideon himself giancarlo
esposito talking about the mandalorian
season 3
season 4 and all the stuff they're going
to be revealing during season 2.
of course i'll be doing episode videos
for the season two episodes when they
release in october so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all those i'll do a new disney plus
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for season two
on the video so just breaking down all
the stuff that he's talking about that
the easter eggs and what it all means
for the future of the show
starting with number five he says we'll
start to learn about baby yoda's true
power
and what he really means what he's
talking about there
is his metaphorical and literal power
metaphorically
what does another member of yoda's race
mean to the future of the star wars
galaxy
in a time period when luke skywalker is
really the only true jedi left
and he's busy trying to rebuild the jedi
order starting with his new academy
the timeline of the mandalorian series
takes place right before
luke skywalker creates that new jedi
academy so it doesn't exist yet right
now when season 2 is taking place
during this early period right after the
events of return of the jedi
luke skywalker is still busy flying all
over the galaxy with han solo leia the
rest of the new republic as it's forming
trying to deal with the remnants of the
empire and former imperial officers that
just stuck around and are trying to
become
warlords controlling different areas of
the galaxy moff gideon is probably the
best example of that on the show there's
no more
empire technically so technically there
are no more moths
even though he still calls himself moff
gideon he was promoted before the fall
of the empire
after the battle of jakku he didn't
leave with the remnants to go to the
unknown regions and turn into the first
order
he stuck around and planned to recreate
the empire according to his own plans so
that's why he's still calling himself a
moth
commanding all these imperial officers
that are left over trying to grab every
single ship and asset that's left over
from the empire that he can get baby
yoda is literally so powerful and full
of so much potential that he's viewed as
a weapon
that maf gideon wants to control but
also wants to use in his implied
grand cloning plans the re-envisioning
of what the empire could be
according to his own plan and speaking
of clones i saw a lot of questions about
this
on the last season 2 trailer video that
i did if it wasn't clear
during the events of season 1 jon
favreau and dave filoni reveal that baby
yoda himself
is not a clone of yoda he was born
naturally to parents of yoda's species
they never revealed who his parents were
i know a lot of people had theories and
posted all the mori
memes of yoda and yaddle but he was born
naturally somewhere in the galaxy
and we'll start to learn more about that
during season two so the cloning plan
that they teased in season one with all
those easter eggs
seems like it's more about moff gideon
using baby yoda's dna
to make a new army of super clones who
are also force sensitive
they kind of teased that concept during
star wars the rise of skywalker with the
sith troopers
it's not really clear what maf gideon
knows about the emperor's grand plans
during this period of galactic history
in his contingencies
there are many different artifacts and
treasure troves of jedi and sith items
that the emperor has stored in vaults
all over the galaxy but moff gideon came
up in the empire as a member of the isb
the imperial security bureau
and that branch is tasked with
information gathering and secret keeping
so it's probably where he learned about
the darksaber before he acquired it but
number four then he also says we'll only
start to uncover the origins of the
darksaber and how that plays into
previous star wars stories the history
of the galaxy
and the movies like the clone wars we
actually already know a lot about the
origin of the darksaber thanks to the
clone wars episodes
the canonical lore behind it is that tar
vizsla an ancient mandalorian from
thousands of years ago who became a big
leader of their people
also became the first mandalorian to
train as a jedi
during that he created his lightsaber as
all jedi do but in order to distinguish
himself
and be unique he used different
materials gave it different properties
with a different focusing crystal
and that turned into the dark saber
called the darksaber because of the
color of its blade
after he died like most jedi's
lightsabers the jedi order stored it in
the archives of the jedi temple
but during the fall of the old republic
there was another war with the
mandalorians and members of house vizsla
used the opportunity to steal the darksaber
from the jedi temple
then passing it down through generations
of their family as a symbol of their
supremacy
until it wound up on the clone wars
series in the hands of the current
leader of their family at the time
pre vizsla who was played by john
favreau himself
the live-action mandalorian character
that he played during season one was
also
called vizsla in the credits so he's
just another member of his clan
also on the clone wars here when the
darksaber showed up for the first time
priy vizla was also the leader of the
death watch clan of mandalorians which
was kind of a separate thing but most of
their family
was part of that group those are the
same mandalorians that came to rescue
dinjaran when he was a child
in episode 8 here so if giancarlo
esposito is saying we're going to learn
more about the history of the darksaber
we'll probably see more of them in
flashbacks too because during this
period
pre vizsla would have been wielding the
darksaber katee sackoff's Bo Katan
Kryze is also supposed to show up
during season two she was also a member
of the death watch clan
and later in the timeline she was also
the last person to wield the dark saber
before moth gideon so she might show up
during the flashbacks
she could also appear in present day but
if she does show up in present day
they'd have to use old age makeup
because she is quite a bit older than
ahsoka
but number three giancarlo besposito
also says we'll get a dramatic sense of
the territory the full breadth of the
star wars universe of characters and
lore
he says there's so much of that to
explore on the show the characters and
the lore
he's talking metaphorically and
literally metaphorically exploring more
of the untouched areas of the star wars
history going back to the mandalorians
history
mandalore the great the mandalorian jedi
wars thousands of years ago like the
knights of the old republic era
those were the references they were
making during the dialogue in the
mandalorian season 2 trailer
there's also the events of the great
purge that they refer to during season 1
that happened during the rise of the
empire that they could also cover
and because the mandalorian is looking
for more jedi and more people of yoda's
race maybe we get to explore more the
unknown regions more of the outer rim
territory planets that we haven't seen
before
canonically it's kind of difficult to
explore the unknown regions though
that's why they create so many issues
like
during rise of skywalker they had to use
the sith holocron to get to exagole
which was in the unknown regions
number two he also says literally
there's so much for them to explore in
terms of new areas of the galaxy that
they previously referenced in star wars
movies and tv shows but that we just
have never actually been to
the mon calamari homeworld is the best
example of that in the mandalorian
season 2 trailer
it's a planet that's mostly covered in
oceans so most of them the mon calamari
and the cora and races that are native
to that planet live beneath the surface
he also says the season 2 episodes are
going to start laying the groundwork for
the much
bigger stories that they'll be telling
in future seasons beyond season two and
they'll finally start answering the
really major questions
in season three and season four so
number one big thing
does that confirm that they're actually
going to do the mandalorian season 4
they've already announced the
mandalorian has been renewed for season
three so that's already a go
but at the time when they did that no
one was talking about how many seasons
the show would actually go on
my early guess when i was doing season
one episodes was that they would try
to get to at least five seasons just
because that's a solid number for a tv
show
because the budget is so big and there
are so many other star wars live action
shows that they're making and
development
in a ton of mandalorian spin-off series
and development too
my take on this is that unofficially
behind the scenes the show has been
renewed for more than just season three
already
and they gave john favreau and dave
filoni the green light to plan
more future seasons worth of story i
don't think they're actually going to start
filming season 3 till the end of
this year or maybe
early next year they haven't really said
yet so all the season three details
we'll get will just be in the form of
teasers and hanging plot threads from
season two episodes
the new season starts october 30th as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those
episodes when i post them but leave all
your requests in the comments below
congratulations chipster321 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big star
wars video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for the full
mandalorian season 2 trailer in easter
eggs and click here for that brand new
avengers Wandavision trailer in marvel
easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way!